are they rooting the fun of weed now we
got to read a [ __ ] menu I know it's a
lot it's a lot but see when you're a
weedologist yeah you know this [ __ ] he
read through the book just like that you
know that [ __ ] friend exactly
did you read through the whole menu
already I got it you got it
[Music]
the last time we saw Seth Rogen you got
to hear this so you were promoting Steve
Jobs yeah you were on the Kelly Ripa
show yeah with Michael Strahan yeah you
wanted to call us I did so you were like
hey I need a landline yes or something I
need somewhere quiet to call what
happened was I had to call it exactly
like 7 45 or whatever it was and and I
was my car there was traffic and so I
got there like a little bit like it was
pushing it and the only room with a
phone that was empty it was literally
like I was looking at two doors and one
was Hugh Jackman's dressing room right
it wasn't Michael Strahan dressing room
right and I was like [ __ ] it I'm going
Michael Strahan on this one yeah because
he's the host and they got to be nice to
you because you're doing the show I went
in there and uh at first it was empty
aside from two uh like women who worked
for him
yeah but that uh they very quickly
wanted me the [ __ ] out of this yeah
Michael walked out well first someone
came in with a song line that said like
you gotta get out of here and I like
waved him off and was like [ __ ] you like
this like and then they left for a few
minutes and then they came came back
with like somehow like a more firmly
written sign that was like seriously
yelling at you you have to get at it
yeah exactly it was all of a sudden all
capitalized with exclamation marks and I
still waved them off and I just wouldn't
leave do you mean he's changing and
they're telling you to get out and you
won't leave no
[Laughter]
[Applause]
on this side of the phone it's not a
joke all right listen to me uh go see
Seth Rogen I think it was one of those
things where the people at the Kelly and
Michael show were worried that Michael
would get mad at them for sticking me in
his dressing room on the phone with you
and that's so funny we got we got so
many emails about it and then like a
bunch of the guys around here were going
you know what we got to do let's get
Seth Rogen to go on his whole tour and
just call us from different directions
[Music]
Seth tells this great story in the book
how he gets a call that Tom Cruise is
now thinking he wants to do comedy the
real comedy is what happened when you
went to see Tom Cruise
this is the movie I love that you had a
pee so bad that you peed into a Snapple
bottle to meet with Tom Cruise I I
stopped halfway up the driveway kind of
in the woods above Sunset Boulevard and
I peed in a Snapple bottle in my car
um and then I uh sealed the bottle and
and left it there and went on to have a
very absurd meeting with with Tom Cruise
but to get to the end yeah so then as I
was leaving the meeting I was sneaking
back down the driveway and I as I was
passing the exact spot that I peeded I
noticed a red light in the woods that
there was a security camera literally
pointed exactly where I was being honest
now I felt your pain on that one I loved
it but the meeting was so bizarre we had
been meeting with him for a long time a
few hours we were talking and he was and
he's and again I said like I'm a huge
Tom Cruise fan like I [ __ ] love Tom
Cruise like I see every Tom Cruise movie
like I go to theater I can't wait he
that man is determined to die on camera
for our entertainment and this meeting
by the way was at the time when he was
married to Katie Holmes and he's just a
baby with her Siri right that was right
when this meeting was was like it was at
the peak of Tom Cruise like I mean I
used the word Mania in a very literal
sense I think in this in this situation
so yeah we met with him for hours and
not a few hours into the meeting he goes
this Scientology stuff comes up how
weird he's looked in the Press lately
kind of how uh yeah just how strange
but he said what you said in the book
was fascinating he said the Press is
trying to make me look crazy because I'm
costing the pharmaceutical industry so
much money because he's against
um
and then yeah the word goes and it's
like with Scientology he said if you let
me just tell you what it was really
about if you let me just give me like 20
minutes so like really just tell you
what it was about you would say no
[ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way I remember being like I I
like the word it was I was like is that
a good thing to be saying yeah
if you let me tell you about Jewish
people you would say no [ __ ] way man
no [ __ ] way
and then I remember there was this very
like loaded moment where he says this to
us if you just gave me like 20 minutes
to tell you about this you would say no
[ __ ] way and be a general look at
each other and I'm like is he gonna bite
am I gonna bite are we how can we come
out of this are we strong enough to have
them do this to us and not be converted
I don't know if I have I I have a weak I
generally a week willed weak-minded
person I would assume on the grand scale
of people like if they got him how what
chance do I have you know
um and thank God Judd was like I think
we're good like let's just talk about
movies and stuff like that right
Dodge that bullet yeah
you know what I find amazing about you
yo you have a writing partner yeah and
you're real successful as a writer and
you've got a production company and I
read something like you guys just sold
four shows or something in production is
that right is that right yeah we have a
few Pilots that were like trying to get
made so you're really successful at
writing a list and the guy who's your
writing partner this kid Evan Goldberg
you met him when you were 12 out of bar
mitzvah yeah Bar Mitzvah class we met up
our Mitzvah class and and it's amazing
to me that you know how old are you now
32. so from the time you're 12 to the
time you're 32 this kid has become your
riding partner you would think like most
times that just wouldn't work out you
know what I mean it's really weird it is
very weird and it's not like lost on me
that we have like a very healthy good
working relationship with one another
I've seen a lot of Partnerships I know I
mean obviously as a writer you know
other partner people who are in
Partnerships and I've seen a lot of them
like evaporate even people who've been
together like for years and years and
years and years yeah some of the great
comedy teams they've all broken up it's
just almost impossible to know someone
since 12 and and do you ever get like
well maybe there are better people at
this for me maybe I'll go right with
this one or that one you never get that
one I've never that's literally never
even occurred to me ever
um no we we like really get along we
work really well together we I mean and
now that we're directing movies together
like I think it's like it's a whole new
thing that we're it's like a whole new
horizon when you direct the movie with
another guy can you get in each other's
way at all very rarely like we'll have
like
short intense disagreements at times but
I'd say 95 of the time were totally on
the same page and like in the we we kind
of have all the arguments that we would
have before the filming of the movie
starts and you know what's kind of cool
too I would think directing with another
person is also kind of securing in a way
because you've got at least somebody you
can bounce off especially if you don't
know how to do something totally and you
that you can talk about it and you you
can instantly get like a little
consensus and it's uh yeah it's I I
would be really nervous doing it alone
honestly
with all your movies success some
writing success and I've talked to you
in the past about how you started out
what I like about you is you're such a
regular guy and and by that I mean your
plan is to go to the comic book store
today yeah yeah and then wait what were
the two places to go into the comic book
store and then you're going to Tokyo toy
Toy Tokyo yeah
but what is the comic book store you
like uh Midtown Comics is a pretty good
comic book what kind of comics do you
read I read all kind of comics I read
like superhero comics uh Marvel Comics
and I read uh kind of I follow writers
more than like the series there's like
who are your faves uh Garth Ennis is one
of my favorite writers see part of part
of the problem with me is yeah like I
haven't kept I used to when I was a kid
I had every comic yeah and now I haven't
kept up and then and then when I get
these compilation books yeah I read the
comics I love comic books yeah but then
to go buy individual copies of comics is
tough because you don't know where the
beginning of the story is that you're in
the middle of it yeah and then you keep
up do you have a subscription to these
Comics No you I'll try to like pick them
up as they start or uh or sometimes you
can go back and catch up on the ones
that you but yeah I mean they're always
starting like little mini series is so
that's kind of what I what I try so you
try to grab the entire Series yeah
definitely I don't like to jump into a
story in the middle but most of these
writers now through like smaller labels
release like their own like they call
them like create our own series and and
they'll be like six comic runs of kind
of just Little original things so when
you go to the comic book store you say
to the guy listen yeah I don't want any
nonsense I want to have a complete story
don't [ __ ] with me man you're right
right listen I'm a celebrity know my
[ __ ] are there a lot of people in there
uh sometimes do they get excited hey
there's Seth Rogen looking at Comics
sometimes comic book fans are generally
kind of shy and nerdy in general so they
they're not up in your [ __ ] too much
they go home and say hey Mom I'm not a
loser exactly he was really high
[Laughter]
one time I was in a bookstore actually
at uh a like 14 year old kid came up to
me and he's like and he was holding two
bucks he's like you're my [ __ ] Idol
man look at what two books I'm buying
and it was a book about screenplay
writing and an encyclopedia of marijuana
people at the store try to assist you
and help you sometimes they do they'll
tell me they could if I if there's
anything I need to order they'll put it
on back order for me because it's quite
Charming that you still do this I mean
you could go on the internet and buy
comic books you don't need to
necessarily but you're looking for new
stuff now you
[Music]
what is Toy Tokyo what is that all about
and what are you doing there uh it's
like uh they sell like vinyl Japanese
toys
you collect that stuff I do a while ago
I got into uh uh a lot of like I don't
know actually makes me sound like a
[ __ ] huge nerd
it's okay uh no not action figures I
collect like a lot of artists I like
make these like vinyl Japanese or with
it not not some some of them are made in
China and Japan but a lot of artists I
like make these vinyl toys and I've been
collecting those for years where do you
display the vinyl toys uh my office has
a lot of them they're kind of around the
house it's kind of a battle to where I
could get them I like it yeah and it's
like pop art to me that's why it's like
they're they're it's it's like pop art
but you seem like a guy who's really
sort of at the same point you have a lot
of friends and this and that but then
there's your solitary Seth Rogen he
writes yeah he smokes and he has his
toys yes exactly my comics and my toys
what should he be smoking the first time
smoker Snoop and then I'll ask you Seth
I would say sativa yeah he should start
with sativa because it's a little bit
lighter yeah and it's more it's more of
a introduction yeah I would probably
actually start with something strong to
make sure you go Indica first no no no
no no I think it's a team but I'm
talking about like what percent should
he start like okay having these like
lower percentage ones but are they
rooting the fun of weed now we gotta
read a [ __ ] menu I know it's a lot
it's a lot but see when you a
weedologist yeah you know this [ __ ] he
went through the book just like that he
know that [ __ ] exactly did you
read through the whole menu already I
got it you got it
I would probably get like a strong like
because there's like some lower
percentage weeds with which some people
like to smoke if they smoke weed all day
like like there's like 14 THC which is
like enough that you will get high but
and if you just gonna wear off it'll
wear off but it it but I think for
someone who just never smoked weed you
might want to start with actually
stronger wheat to make sure you actually
feel something because you might not but
again one [ __ ] yes hit yes if you hit
this [ __ ] one time yeah no [ __ ]
ass gonna be done yeah
JD is wearing a special shirt for his
introduction keeping up with the theme
today
there's plans
stoop what's with this shirt
on that [ __ ] or something that
we recognize ain't no cactus in the hood
you gotta tell the story I don't even
know if Charlize knows about this but
weed does get you in trouble
occasionally didn't you finally like
meet Stephen Spielberg who I guess is
like you know the guy to me yeah and and
and you were in the like smoking a joint
in front of him yes
what happened how was that
I was oh man and it's it's why I mean
not it's probably why I'm not like in a
lot of students
my talent is probably also but I was at
a party yeah and it was it was party was
it a big party like I think it was that
Jeffrey katzenberg night before party
that he would hatch a video it's like a
big party with a lot of famous people at
it and I start I was outside and there
was someone else I knew and we started
smoking weed and I was smoking a joint
and like it was this Awkward Moment
where like Steven Spielberg came up to
be like as I had this joyed in my hand
and I could just tell like he he did not
like it like it was a very judgmental
moment and then you're confronted with
this thing where it's like do I [ __ ]
try to hide it
joint in front of Steven Spielberg
um
yeah and yes and I I he always I've run
into him a few times and he always seems
a little disappointed in me so the whole
time you're talking to him yeah you said
that's it I gotta go I just gotta
[ __ ] smoke this [ __ ] I gotta down
this thing while face to face with
Steven Spielberg when you were a young
comic you were about to go on at 14 and
you were auditioning for something big
just for last Festival why is that such
a big deal it's the biggest Comedy
Festival in in North America probably
the world the story went that you were
about to audition yeah and all of a
sudden they go ladies and gentlemen
Jerry Seinfeld just popped in yeah and
he wants to and Seinfeld was already
well known right I mean yeah I mean it
was literally the peak of his show I
think it was like the two years before
it went off the air like it was still on
so he was a big [ __ ] well he was the
biggest star on the planet by all means
and so you're 14 years old Just for
Laughs the festival must have been like
the most important thing in your
Universe yeah it would probably been
rehearsing sort of going over your
materials for months the year was like
1990. I've flown to Los Angeles to do
the audition and you probably had to
convince your parents and they came with
me right a whole big deal yeah 14 years
old and then they go excuse me uh kid uh
Jerry Seinfeld just walked in the room
and he's going up they said he's coming
they said I think Jerry said it was it
was as the comic on me was kind of
before like he had a few minutes left
and they were like Seinfeld's coming he
might make it he might not make it till
after you and I was like oh [ __ ] did it
throw off your whole game oh yeah it was
well also like after signed for so he
got there right before me and went on
and he kills and annihilates like
classic because he's also Jerry Seinfeld
who's got the number one television show
he's the most famous comedian on the
planet and he's his and he's one of the
best comedians right on the planet and
at that time I think what he was
actually preparing for is he had this
special where he stopped doing all his
old materials
and in preparation for that he was
honing all of his best material to the
sharpest Edge you could possibly have
perfect and so it was literally like
like following like a Led Zeppelin
Greatest Hits concert and so he just
like annihilates and then he leaves and
then I go on after and you stand there
and watch more do you say I'll avoid
watching him because I don't want to
feel like I remember I watched half of
it and then I was like I can't even I
[ __ ] like went out into the
restaurant area I was like I can't even
continue watching it oh my God yeah are
your parents there with you kind of
trying to console you my mom was there
just I'm sure she was
her being star-struck over Seinfeld
probably just superseded any sympathy
she had for me in that moment are all
the other comedians laughing at you that
you have to follow Seinfeld yeah they it
was just like a disaster after a guy
like that kills the laughs are so
intense and the excitement is so intense
that anyone who comes on afterwards
there's no way to recover you can't even
say to the audience hey man I [ __ ]
suck man this is ridiculous no and as a
kid
I was already overcoming something like
a large like the first few minutes of my
ACT were were overcoming the fact like
on the best of circumstances we're
overcoming the fact that I was a 14 year
old kid and you assume it's a gimmick
anyone in their right mind assumes a 14
year old kid is not [ __ ] funny
yeah it's just gonna suck or it's gonna
give it to be annoying and I really
tried not to do that so I I really tried
to like build the trust of the audience
so like no I'm an actual comedian and so
it was like a double strike against me
and it was to this day like I have a
visceral sense memory of being on that
stage and just like eating [ __ ] [ __ ]
as hard as you can you think you ate
[ __ ] or do you think that's just in your
mind I knew I ate [ __ ] and the other
thing that happened was also because I
didn't it was one I think it was my
first time performing in America and I
didn't also understand that there were
like cultural different like in
Vancouver where I'm from like everyone
takes the bus it's not like you're not a
[ __ ] weirdo if you're on the bus but
in Los Angeles in 1995 you don't think
you are a [ __ ] weirdo if you're on
the bus and so so you're doing bus
material and people Robert
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
and so it was like I was like oh my God
and I just remember like okay I'm
following so I felt I'm 14. nobody's
ever been on a [ __ ] bus in their
[ __ ] lives what is happening and uh I
just remember hearing the butt like I
literally that sound is tattooed in my
brain is the electronic hum off of the
speakers
and I just remember and I literally
remember like being on stage and
stopping to talk for a moment to allow
my brain to process the thought of like
I've never heard the electronic Buzz
coming off the speakers as a 14 will
have to experience some pretty good
stand-ups oh yeah I had done it like I
started when I was 13 but I performed
very regularly so I had I had done you
know dozens of shows by then I mean you
know it's not even funny with Comics
that's the thing they always remember
most the the shitty ones the ones where
they change still happening what's funny
is like I it's sick and it is how my
brain works as sick as like all you know
I don't like ravenously Devour the
reviews to our movies but I like to know
what the consensus is and even if
there's a really good review if there's
one sentence
that bothers me that's all I like days
later I'll be like the [ __ ] does that
guy be the art Direction wasn't up to
stop it